tout ce que vous dites je l' ai vécu
avec ma grand mère qui est décédée en
septembre elle était dans un ehpad et on
était très malheureux ça fait
culpabiliser les familles aussi parce
que on n'avait pas d'autre choix n'avait
pas d'autre solution on se relayait on y
allait quasiment tous les jours et même
en y allant tous les jours il manquait
toujours quelque chose du papier et des
choses vraiment de la dignité de base
quoi de la dignité humaine de du papier
toilette des serviettes hygiéniques on
leur en acheter nous mêmes on lui rend
plus acheter un petit frigo parce
qu'effectivement elle avait faim elle se
réveilla l'a perdue elle faisait à la
fin elle faisait peut-être 30 kg enfin
c'était vraiment incroyable
et donc j'ai vécu on appelait quant à
elle appelé sur le bouton rouge parce
qu'elles ont ils ont un bouton rouge
personne ne venait pendant des heures
une fois ma mère a fait le test en
chambre elle a attendu deux heures un
après midi avant que quelqu'un vienne
enfin tout ce que vous décrivez à tous
les niveaux en fait c'est la nourriture
mais est effectivement il ya des
infirmières qui sont formidables qui
portent à bout de bras des personnes
âgées qui se casse le dow et c donc on
peut pas les blâmer ya juste pas assez
de personnel il ya des listes d'attenté
quand on râlait on nous disait oh vous
savez si vous n'êtes pas contente vous
pouvez en gros vous pouvez dégager mais
nous on n'avait pas de solution parce
que ma grand mère était elle avait 101
ans quand elle est décédée elle avait
elle été trop dépendantes il n'y avait
pas d'autre solution et donc nous on
penser aussi aux gens qui n'ont pas de
visite parce que nous on y allait tous
les jours mais il ya des gens qui n'ont
aucune visite et là c'est vraiment la
catastrophe le coc vide a aggravé les
choses avec les confinements isolement
chambre les masques il faut savoir que
ces gens finissent leur vie aujourd'hui
en ne voyant pas un visage humain il ne
voit que des masques c'est absolument
terrible voilà et je pourrais en parler
je vais pas en parler pendant des heures
mais je voudrais monopoly mais c'est
vraiment terrible il y a une
culpabilisation nous on s'en remet pas
parce qu'on n'avait pas de pardon on
n'avait pas le choix on savait pas quoi
faire d'autre elle a dû ventes sont à
part son petit appartement ma grand-mère
pour payer le lait pourtant c'est
effectivement il ya une grosse partie
qui est remboursé par là par la sécurité
sociale mais ça ne devrait pas tous bons
et on faisait tout ce qu'on pouvait en
lui amener chaque jour des pâtisseries
des choses et tout aimé voilà et de se
vouer le pire je vais vous dire le pire
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de ces personnes
de ses résidents qui ont encore leur
leur tête et qui se voit être là bas et
qui comprennent tous qu'ils voient qu'on
a deux minutes pour les laver qui se
sentent brutalisé dans leur intimité
elles sont tout nus dans des douches
debout et tous ces horribles et c'est ça
le pire je crois que c'est c'est la
partie psychologique à la limite parce
que les gens savent que c'est voilà
c'est comme ça qu'ils vont finir leur
vie et c'est vraiment terrible quoi